as we approach one full year of covert
restrictions there's new data confirming
that a baby boom that some doctors and
for that matter comedians expected
is actually turning out to be a major
baby bust
health departments in 27 states provided
records to cbsnews.com
and they show a seven percent drop in
bursts in december that would be nine
months after the first
lockdowns began and it could be just the
beginning researchers say it matches
a much bigger plunge in fertility that
is decades in the making
the number of babies the average woman
is expected to deliver in her lifetime
has dropped from nearly
four in the 1950s to less than two today
and that could present an entirely
different threat to society as we know
it
than we were first warned about decades
ago
the stakes in this battle are far
greater than any other we have ever
fought
in the 1960s and 70s an apocalyptic fear
gripped america
the experts we interviewed told us
population was the fundamental crisis
as the world stampeded toward 10 billion
people
many researchers predicted that
overpopulation
would ruin us sometime in the next 15
years the end will come and by the end i
mean an
utter breakdown of the capacity of the
planet to support humanity
but these days
a very different note from researchers
like usc professor dal myers who studies
demographic trends
the trouble is that we overshot we
dropped it down too much now
while the global population is still
growing a major study last summer
predicted it'll actually peak in 2064
and then fall by nearly a billion people
by the end of the century
the reason fewer babies here in the us
in fact we're already below the
so-called replacement level by some
measures
and that means fewer young people to
support our otherwise
aging population that's a crisis we need
to have enough
working age people to carry the load of
these seniors who deserve their
retirement
they deserve all their entitlements and
they're going to live out another 30
years
nobody in the history of the globe has
had so many older people to deal with
and the pandemic is only making this
problem worse despite some early jokes
that more families staying home together
might mean more babies we thought oh we
would see a baby boom
but we just haven't seen it dr david
jasmine is chair of the department of
gynecology and obstetrics at einstein
medical center in philadelphia
he says patients are worried about not
only their health but their finances
so you're hearing more people ask you
about contraception and fewer people say
we're thinking about trying that's
absolutely true
i get a report every morning at 5 15
about what has happened in the last 24
hours and the first
report that i see is a number of
deliveries in the last 24 hours
it's less than it used to be the
question now is
how low will it go the brookings
institution has predicted a large
lasting baby bust of at least 300 000
fewer children
in 2021 we are on the precipice
at the very least of not having enough
children to replace our population
and so what i mean well that's the
interesting question right laura
lindberg tracks reproductive data for
the guttmacher institute
and while she's also seeing the baby
bust she views it as a sign of progress
a marker of women's equality and freedom
of choice
so it's a shift to later in life in that
shift comes more education
more career more employment so it's a
reordering of how people engage in
adulthood
dal myers doesn't disagree but in the
bigger picture he worries our declining
birth rate is also
a barometer of despair in 1978 when you
were breaking into the field
did you ever think in your lifetime
you'd be talking about a declining birth
rate globally
no so what changed the burdens of life
the cost of housing the cost of
education
all these things are have become more
and more difficult
i think the boomers themselves don't
realize that how much harder it is for
millennials today
and they think oh yeah we were young we
had to live you know
on very little money and we made do and
you can do the same
that's the story right well i know it
really is a lot harder for the young
people today
it's amazing how much harder it is yeah
see how i slipped in that millennial
propaganda
but i think that's true though yeah but
it's a very important point i think
yeah so on the one hand it is a story of
equality and and choice but there are
people out there who want to have
kids but don't feel they can because
their finances are a mess or they have
huge college loan debt or they can't
afford a home or child care is crazy
so it sounds like it was strictly
finances but do you think part of it is
you're at home and you're just really
getting on each other's nerves
well yeah so yeah everybody there's also
i just don't like you right now
everybody's having less sex right now
single people included but the people
who are having the least sex are people
with children
every night actually in my home we have
to clean the kitchen and there's a big
window and
katie's always joking that we're putting
on an advertisement for safe sex because
as we picked as a big spills off the
floor like
a swiffer all night long like this uh
you know the crayon markings on the
fireplace
maybe putting in an advertisement for
safe sex but there is a baby coming
there's a baby there is a baby
guy you are the outlier